this is jocko podcast number 323 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening also joining
us tonight is jason gardner good evening
jason good evening
the inspiration of a noble cause
involving human interest far and wide
enables men to do things they did not
dream themselves capable of before
and which they were not capable of alone
the consciousness of belonging vitally
to something beyond individuality
of being part of a personality that
reaches we know not where in space and
time
greatens the heart to the limits
of the soul's ideal
and builds out the supreme of character
it was something like this i think which
marked our motive which made us strong
to fight the bitter fight to the
victorious end and made us
unrevengeful
in that
victory we rose in soul above the things
which even the declaration of
independence pronounces the inannual
rights of human nature
for the securing of which governments
are instituted among men happiness
liberty
life
we laid on the altar of offering
or committed to the furies of
destruction while our minds were lifted
up to a great thought
and our hearts swelled to its measure
we were beckoned on by the vision of
destiny we saw our country moving
forward charged with the sacred trusts
of man
we believed in its glorious career the
power of high aims and of strong purpose
the continuity of great endeavor
the onward upward path of history to god
[Music]
every man felt that he gave himself to
and belonged to something beyond time
and above place something which could
not die
these are the reasons
not
fixed in the form of things
but formative of things
reasons of the soul why we fought for
the union
and this is the spirit in which having
overcome the dark powers of denial and
disintegration having restored the
people of the south to their place and
privilege in the union
and set on high the old flag telling of
one life and one body one freedom and
one law over all the people and all the
land between
the four great waters
we now come as it were home
we look into each other's eyes
we speak in softer tones
we gather under the atmosphere of these
sacred thoughts and memories
like the high pure air that shines down
upon us today flooding these fields
fields where cloud and flash and thunder
roll of battle and shrouded us and them
in that great three days burial
to celebrate this resurrection
to rear on these far away field
memorials of familiar names
and to honor the state
whose honor it was to rear such manhood
and those are remarks
that were delivered on october 3rd
1889 by general
joshua chamberlain
who
with the 20th maine led the defense of
the left flank of the union army
on a hill known as little round top
during the battle of gettysburg
and joshua
chamberlain was an incredible soldier
an incredible leader a warrior a scholar
a thinker
he's most well known
for his deeds as a military leader
he received the medal of honor for his
heroic leadership there in gettysburg
that was only part of his life he served
served only four years in the army
but during that time he participated in
some of the fiercest fighting of the war
over 20 engagements including
fredericksburg
chancellorsville gettysburg spotsylvania
cold harbor petersburg and five forks he
was wounded six times during battle
two of those times nearly fatal
he was chosen by grant
to receive the first flag of surrender
at the appomattox courthouse on april 12
1865.
then went on to be elected governor of
maine four times
served as president of bowdoin college
he was a lawyer he was a real estate
developer
at the age of 70
even though his health had been severely
impacted by his war wounds
he volunteered to lead troops in the
spanish-american war
he was denied by the secretary of war
he wrote
and he wrote a book called bayonet
forward
my civil war
reminiscences
and we're going to cover it today jason
and i have had the privilege of walking
the battlefield of gettysburg
we do an event at echelon called ef
battlefield
and during that event we
we look at all the different leaders
and there's a bunch of different leaders
and
with a bunch of different personalities
the good the bad the ugly we got mead
and lee we got beaufort and long street
hancock and yule
sickles and stewart and and every one of
those
[Music]
people
and and there's many more that we we
discussed there on the battlefield there
are
complex people
in a complex situation making complex
leadership decisions
some right
some wrong some insignificant some
completely consequential
but for
me the one individual
that stands out from all those leaders
is joshua chamberlain with so many
lessons to learn
and we're going to explore explore some
of those
today as we go through some highlights
of his book
does anyone stand out more than joshua
chamberlain when you go to gettysburg i
mean they all stand out mead stands up
lee stands out long street buford they
all
have these dynamic moments good and bad
but
as far as just
overall when you look at the whole thing
together
just from gettysburg
chamberlain is he stands out in an epic
way
the whole experience of being on that
battlefield is almost impossible to put
into words
because there's
there's more to it it's not like we're
in a classroom and we're learning about
the history of stuff there isn't there's
there's something that i can't explain
that you feel
when you're there and he
he touched on this in a speech that he
gave later and i was like oh okay
what he said was
in great deed something abides on great
fields something stays
forms change and pass bodies disappear
but spirits linger to consecrate the
ground for the vision place of souls
and irreverent men and women from afar
and generations that know us not
and that we know not of
heart drawn to see where and by whom
great things were suffered and done for
them
shall come to this deathless field to
ponder and dream and low
the shadow of a mighty presence shall
wrap them in its bosom and the power of
the vision pass into their souls
and that's what it's like you're there
and you feel like you're part of
something that's bigger than you and the
it's just an it's it's it's an immensely
yeah i'm i'll say it it's it's a
life-changing experience to go to that
battlefield as an american
yeah there's
[Music]
there's something spiritual that goes
down for lack of a better word i don't
know what other word to use
i'm not even 100 sure i know what the
words natural means i think that's the
best i don't know what else to say when
when you
when you walk on that battlefield and
when you know what happened and when you
know the cost and when you know what the
consequences were
we're going to be to win or lose there
that everything that we have and the
course of history as we know it in the
course of free people in the world like
it all is there in this one little area
where
thousands of of of men stood toe-to-toe
sometimes literally against their
relatives
and you know you when we walk that
battlefield we point that out certain
battles where there's literally
relatives fighting against each other
and just to know the course of human
history and and that that
point in time
and how important it was
it's
it is it's like a spiritual thing to be
there
um
possibly the most decisive
battle of the civil war
because if things had gone the other way
it would have affected the election and
all and and when you actually walk there
and you see that things were
literally held by a thread
yeah i mean
case in point the 20th main on the left
length of the union army
attack after attack after attack and
we'll get to it um
all right i'm going to go to the book
going to the battle of fredericksburg
this is virginia
december
11th through the 15th 1862. by the way i
didn't check on the weather but december
1862 this was crazy
so we make boots right at origin
the they they the boots that these guys
wore were boots called single last boots
and what that means is they don't have a
left foot and a right foot there's just
one
shape for the boots and it's a wooden
sole
so it's a piece of wood with leather
attached to it and you get a left and
right is the same that's like the
comfort level that these dudes are in
it's a freaking nightmare
here we go
so
we were held in reserve
it may be thought that we were glad to
be kept out of the fight at least for
the present
but i take occasion to say that in
forming for a great fight it is not
regarded as a very special favor to be
held in reserve
the holding is most likely not for long
and it holds itself a peculiar stress
and strain waiting and watching intent
and anxious stirred by the pulse of
manhood and the contagion of comradeship
conscious of the strength to help but
forbidden to strike
all this wears sorely on every generous
spirit this guy is such a freaking
incredible writer it's mind-boggling but
that is such a
great thing and as soon as i was reading
i was like this is the first thing i'm
going to read in this book because
only if you've been sitting on the
battlefield when there's something
happening and you can't do anything or
you're being held quote in reserve
and you know what it feels like to be
like oh i want to go help but i can't
and my what does he say my manhood wants
to go help but i can't
but then he gets this
then he says this
and that other not unmanly impulse if
the worst is coming let us meet it
may have its part two in the drama it is
really less trying to go in first and
deliver your blow in the flush of spirit
and strength with the feeling that if
the worse comes you will be reinforced
or relieved
then to be held back till some dire
disaster calls when the life and death
grapple clinches and you must recover
lost ground or die trying that's another
crazy thing like when you're in the
reserves hey if everything goes good
you're not doing anything
and if everything goes bad you're gonna
go jump into this freaking mayhem and
get some the worst place yeah the worst
possible place or on the other hand you
can be called to advance in triumph over
a field already carried something then
is lacking to the manly sense of service
rendered according to strength so this
reserve for him is a lose-lose situation
you're either getting called into a
freaking blood bath
in which case this is gonna be horrible
and you didn't have the chance to strike
when you were like ready to rock and
roll
or they're gonna win and you know you
just get to roll in there and be like
well you guys did a good job high five
you know
that's got to be an uncomfortable
feeling
uh
[Music]
it says um
this is this is good or bad depending on
your reserve state of mind we could
plainly see the fierce struggle of our
second and nine core lines first
steadily moving forward in perfect order
and array the flag high poised and
leading checked and broken somewhat on
each successive rise under the first
range of shot and shell
no musket replying this would for this
would have been worse than useless but
bright bayonets fixed ready at the final
reach to sweep like a sharp wave crest
over the enemy's rock-like barrier so
he's watching this unfold and you can
see the you can see the soldiers kind of
coming up out of the rise of you know
coming up on a little a little knoll and
then sinking back down and they're
watching this
he says right on
then reaching the last slope before and
beneath the death delivering stone wall
suddenly aloomed by a sheet of flame and
in an instant the whole line sinking as
if swallowed up in the earth the bright
flags quenched in gloom
and only a writhing mass marking that
high tide halt of uttermost manhood and
supreme endeavor
so these guys march up to that wall
and then
you know however many confederate
soldiers just engage
and that blast of those rounds at close
range and it just immediately stops them
then a slow backflowing
with despairing effort here and there to
bear back broken bodies of the brave
glorified by the baptism of blood
i'm just gonna go throw out some little
i gotta go english major here for a
minute but that alliteration right there
that alliteration there to bear back
broken bodies of the brave glorified by
the baptism of blood this guy gets an a
plus on that
good lord
freaking incredible
again and again the bold essay repeated
by other troops with similar experience
and thickening ridges of the fallen
marking the desperate assays
there we stood for an hour
witnessing five immortal charges
tears ran down the cheeks of stern men
waiting almost wishing wishing to be
summoned to the same futile glorious
work
[Music]
so there's these guys
standing up in reserve watching five
charges watching guys get mowed down
they're crying as they're watching their
friends get killed and wishing
to be called in to do their duty
just to get it over with
yeah
if you're standing in line to go into a
meat grinder yeah do you want to be the
first one or like 30 back watching it
come slow good grief
now came the call for the reserves
burnside despairing of the left and
seeing the heroic value on the right at
last exhausted in unavailing sacrifice
ordered in the fifth core griffin's
division to lead first came the silent
departure of our first and second
brigades whose courage our eyes could
not follow
we waited
in expectation not in fear for that has
little place in manhood when love and
duty summon but eager to do our best and
make the finish few words were spoken
among officers however endeared to each
other by confidence is deepened by such
pressure of life on the borders of death
as war compels
the sense of responsibility silenced all
else
[Music]
silence in the ranks too
one little word perhaps telling whom to
write to
griffin gave us a searching wistful look
not trusting his lips and we
not needing more
now rang forth
the thrilling bugle cry
third regrade
to the front
i don't know man i don't know if i have
any comments
you know like
this guy is such an incredible writer
and
[Music]
the way he conveys this
it just doesn't need anything else
the story about this night
was what really i highlighted on this
battle and struck me
when they eventually have to hold up for
the night yeah even on bodies oh yeah
first comes the charge
we were directed straight forward toward
the left of the futile advance we had
seen so fearfully cut down
the fences sued compelled us to send our
horses back the artillery fire made
havoc crushed bodies severed limbs were
everywhere around in streets door yards
and gardens our man be our men began to
fall and were taken up by the faithful
surgeons and hospital attendants who
also bring courage to their work
now we reach the lines we were to pass
for the further goal
we picked our way amid bodies thickly
strewn some stark and cold some silent
with slowly ebbing life some in sharp
agony that must have voice
though unavailing
some prone from sheer exhaustion or by
final order of hopeless commander
the living from their close clung bosom
of the earth strove to dissuade us it's
no use boys we've tried that nothing
living can stand there it's only for the
dead
on we pushed
up slopes slippery with blood
miri with repeated unavailing tread we
reached that final crest before that
all-commanding countermanding stone wall
here we exchanged fierce volleys at
every disadvantage until the muzzle
flame deepened the sunset red
and all was dark
we stepped back a little behind
the shelter in this forlorn foremost
crest and sank to silence
perhaps
such as human weakness
to sleep
so as they're marching on this assault
where they've watched five charges fail
as they're stepping over bodies and
limbs
and guys some laying quietly dialing and
dying and some screaming out in agony
and some laying wounded are looking up
at them and saying stop it's no use
don't go we already tried it
and they press on
and they basically get into a gunfight
at that wall and then it gets dark
and this is the this is the part that
you're talking about is a cold night
bitter raw north wind swept stark slopes
the men heated by their energetic and
exciting work
felt keenly the chilling change
i rose at midnight
as we advanced over that stricken field
the grave conglomerate monotone resolved
itself into its diverse several elements
some breathing inarticulate agony
some deer home names some begging for a
drop of water some caring for
some for a caring word some praying god
for strength to bear some for life some
for quick death
we did what we could
but how little it was on a field so
boundless for
feeble human reach so they're just up
there
laid up
sleeping
with
with the dead and the dying
by the way i'm not reading this whole
book you and i were talking earlier on i
said hey it's going to be hard it was
hard for me to pick out like what am i
going to read because
literally this book you could just read
the entire thing just do the book i
could just do that and just call it just
be like hey i'm just going to read this
whole thing
um
and maybe i will do that this is
probably there's no way this is being
protected by
copyright or anything like that because
it's too old so maybe i'll just do an
audio book get that out there as well my
dad just tried to get a copy of it and
it wasn't readily available he had to
get it like from an outside seller on
amazon oh the book itself this one yeah
yeah it won't it'll be reprinted now
which is awesome but me i'll have to
just go straight audio book on this
thing
hats off to you because there's some
words in here i'm not used to
yeah
it's it's not that bad there's worse
he's he he even though they're
definitely i i think
there's definitely words that are
challenging but it's still he speaks
pretty plainly you know
uh i mean compared to some stuff
from back in the day it was really back
in the day uncle charles
he's a plain speaker
but man
it's funny i never picked up on that
alliteration and he's
i didn't pick up on it because i haven't
been reading it out loud as soon as you
start reading out loud
that alliteration have you ever read the
sheamus haney version of beowulf
no okay so beowulf the way it's written
in
what is it old english
um
god i hope i got that right yeah it's
old english
it's written the way that they wrote
it's written with alliteration so all
the sounds are
and
it's like the same
vowels right
and so when sheamus haney did the
translation into modern english he
managed to find words to make the whole
thing have that same alliteration
throughout the book it's
it's
powerful that guy's got to be a wizard
oh yeah yeah
he's he seems super smart
i think he's like one of the most uh
recognized
you know they there's that thing people
do where they're like hey
what's the one person that you'd like to
have dinner with dead or alive
like to fill out those questions
definitely
you could sit for hours yeah with uh
joshua yeah and just listen to him talk
because it's like it took me a second it
was like getting in a cold swimming pool
to get used to it and then once i was
used to it i was like
gosh i really like the way that he
speaks yeah and
and then you know sometimes i'll i would
send like
text iris
like hey i'm going to endeavor to get
the kids ready for school and then my
efforts will be pointed towards
ensuring that the horses are fed uh
yeah no he's and mimicking because his
stuff is awesome
yep um
the
so these guys are up there all night
it's a it's a horror show
it's a horror show
um
no big deal just sleeping on dead guys
fast forward a little bit awakened by
the sharp fire
soon came a storm of bullets from the
front and flank to route us from our
slight shelter in the hollow between the
two outermost crests of the manifold
assault not suff this not sufficing the
artillery took up the task trying to
rain down shell upon us and sweep solid
shot through our huddled group
we had to lie flat on the earth
and only by careful twisting could any
man load and fire his musket against the
covered line in the front
before long we saw two or three hundred
of the enemy creep out from the right of
their stone wall and take advantage of a
gully bank where the ground fell away
from our left to get a full flank fire
on us the situation was critical
we took a warrant of supreme necessity
we laid up a breastwork of dead bodies
to cover that exposed flank
behind this we managed to live through
the day
no man could stand up and not be laid
down again hard
i saw a man lift his head by the prop of
his hands and forearms and catch a
bullet in the middle of his forehead
such recklessness was forbidden
we lay there all day
hearing the dismal thud of the bullets
into the dead flesh of our life-saving
bulwarks
no relief could dare to reach us
reinforcements we did not wish
so they get flanked
and they have to build a wall of their
dead friends to protect them
fast forward a little bit
they get ordered back to
fredericksburg
knight came again and midway of it the
order to remove and take respite within
the city
we had to pick our way over a field
strewn
with incongruous ruin
men torn and broken and cut to pieces in
every indescribable way
cannon dismounted gun carriages smashed
or overturned ammunition chests flung
wildly about horses dead and half dead
still held in harness accoutrements of
every sort scattered as by whirlwinds
it was not good for the nerves that
ghastly march
in the lowering night
just after midnight of this miserable
day we were summoned three regiments of
us to set forth on some special service
we knew not what or where something very
serious we must believe
we were bound for the extreme front
to form a picket line to cover the
center of the field while the army was
to take some important action
colonel ames commanded our line the
regiment coming under my charge
the last order came in low tones
hold this ground at all hazards
and to the last
a strange query crossed our minds last
of what
no dictionary held that definition
as a general term
this reached
the infinite
we were pretty well buried and braced
for the coming dawn when a strange
clatter came up from the left rear and a
gasping voice called where is the
commander of these troops
i acknowledge that responsibility get
yourselves out of this quick as god will
let you the whole army is across the
river was the message heard no doubt by
the whole hostile picket line this was a
critical moment something must be said
and then and done quickly steady in your
places my men i ordered
one or two of you arrest this stampeder
this is a ruse of the enemy
we'll give it to them in the morning
this was spoken with no suppressed or
hesitating tone but pitched for the
benefit of our astonished neighbors in
double darkness in our front
my men caught the keynote of my policy
trusted my discretion and held
themselves quiet
talk about badass
quick thinking too so he's up there
freaking with their picket line where
they're expecting this massive fight and
somebody comes up on horseback
and says hey the whole entire army's
across the way get out of here as quick
as you can go
and he knows this guy's an imposter
and just stays calm and cool and says it
loud enough so that the enemy can hear
him
uh
i stepped back to the staff officer and
rebuked him severely for his rashness
pointing out to him the state of things
vexed at having to moderate even this
even my stress of voice
he explained he had had such a time
getting over the field on up to hit this
front line he'd almost lost his wits so
that was a union guy
no
oh yes yes yeah and he was quick enough
to go hey
arrest this enemy guy and he's like hey
come here buffoon yeah
yeah you almost made everybody run away
i stepped back to the staff officer
reviewed him severely for his rashness
even cooler hitting out to him the state
of things
vexed at having
to moderate even the stress of my voice
which
something that we talk about all the
time is like staying calm
and
that's an important thing
and even the way you speak is going to
impact other people around you and he
knows that
vexed is a word that i need to use more
yeah vexed is a good word
uh one of my friends growing up he had
another friend
that oh no he had a uh
adopted brother that was from like um
somewhere in the islands
like jamaica or something
and he would do something that would
make his
his brother mad his brother would say
you're vexing me
[Laughter]
so i think that's a good good time for
this um
good let's let's bring back that word
uh
order comes to leave so eventually they
do get they do get the order to leave
it was a dreary retreat down those rec
strewn slopes it was hard enough to be
stumbling over torn up sods groups of
the dead or forms of the solitary dying
muskets dropped with quick relax or held
fast with death's convulsive clutch
swords bayonets cartridge boxes
fragments of everything everywhere but
when a ghastly gleam of moonlight fell
on the pale faces fixed and stark and on
open eyes that saw not
but reflected utter most things it sent
a shiver through us
i'm not used to fighting in the dark
right can you imagine this these guys
they they're completely in the dark yeah
yeah and we we always with night vision
or we could put flares up or whatever
yeah
it's just dark
what a mess
the potential for blue on blue and some
of the stuff he talks about where he
like
he's trying to straighten up his guys
and winds up talking to a confederate
soldier about where he's dated
it's freaking nuts dude
is crazy
yeah
it's kind of at least the other people
can't see either i guess yeah no one can
no one can see
did you ever go on any of those did you
ever go to the jungle in the night
yeah i went down into jungle training in
panama yeah i did that and then
basically we learned like you're not
doing anything at night you could stop
yeah you have to stop
and you could patrol real
quiet and slow but like once you got
into an iad it was a total disaster
that's why the guys like the seals and
nom that would patrol at night
and set up an ambush
they probably pop flares they well i
don't think they patrolled very far
either no it's true because you had to
move so slow right one of the vietnam
vets was telling me that they wouldn't
go further than like 500 yards into the
jungle and that was and that would take
like two hours three hours and typically
up a canal
so they were in the water most of the
way and then out a little bit
it's a little easier to move in the
water yeah
and it's the moon has a big impact in
the desert but in the jungle it's a lot
less of an impact none like because
you're under a triple canopy
um
did you go down to panama yeah yeah so
that you got those
black palms black palms which
essentially is like why get barbed wire
just plant black palms everywhere black
palms are a tree that are just covered
in little thorns they're not little
they're pretty big
and
what sucks is when you're moving at
night and you grab a hold of what you
think is a tree to help you step over
something and you just end up with nine
black palm freaking thorns in your hand
yeah i don't i don't know how you can do
it
you just gotta you gotta stop and wait
yeah you gotta move slow but at least
like after a while your night vision
could adjust and you could be like okay
i can we can move but as soon as we did
an eye ad at night and you're shooting
and your night vision is just out the
window that's when it was just
that's when it's complete blackness
they had us do like three eye ads at
night just so we knew
what it was like and what the risks were
we were doing some training for a while
called the emp training right what if we
go to war with someone and there's we
don't have
night vision or any of that other stuff
and so that was great because some of
the vietnam vets were contracting for us
and they were talking about being able
to smell
the enemy they're like we'll walk down
trails and we got our hands on the guy's
shoulder in front of us because we can't
see and we we don't want to risk getting
lost and then sometimes we could smell
the enemy coming
before
they actually showed up and they the
example he gave
was uh there was a female with the
vietnamese and he could smell her
shampoo
and then just start shooting you know
it's like when you can they're that
close that you're smelling them before
you're seeing them it's just crazy
um
he's got a section here
to he says why we lost why the battle
was lost
[Music]
he says perhaps the main cause and he
goes into some other details i'm going
to jump a little bit here
he says perhaps the main cause of this
great disaster the commander of the
center grand division did not put his
men in
they were sent by superior orders in
detachments to support other commands as
a forlorn hope at various times and
places during the unexpected
developments or rather the almost
inevitable accidents of the battle
it should not have been a disaster
franklin with his 60 000 men should have
turned lee's right whereas he attacked
with only two divisions and at one at a
time and did not follow up with this
whole force with their splendid
initiative
this is you know all about prioritizing
execute you know you're doing a little
bit trying to solve this problem trying
to solve that problem trying to solve
another problem it's like what is our
major problem and not keeping things
simple either that's true too yeah
when franklin failed it was rashness to
to expect sumner
to carry the formidable heights beyond
the city made impregnable by lee's best
skill and valor that front might have
been held still under menace while
sumner reinforced perhaps by the main
body of hooker's grand division might
have concentrated upon lee's left above
the city and flanked the formidable
bastions crowning the heights that
entrenched his front with all that earth
and manhood could do
that battle was not fought according to
burdenside's intention
and that his plan was mutilated by
distrust and disharmony among his
subordinates commanders does not
exonerate him this is going back to
napoleon right
look just speak if i tell you to do
something i tell if i tell jason to do
something i tell echo to do something
and you guys
don't like me or you don't like my plan
and so you go do something else that's
not your fault that's my fault for not
fixing it and not getting you engaged in
the plan and not letting accepting your
input and asking what your opinion is
it is the first great trust and place of
a chief commander to control reluctant
and incongruous elements and to make his
and to make subordinates and opponents
submit to his imperial purpose
now i'll tell you what's the best way to
get someone to submit to your imperial
purpose is by saying hey justin how do
you want to assault this target yeah
that's the best way not by saying hey
here's here's what i'm imposing upon you
to do
and you can take those words the wrong
way and i don't think that's how he met
him
like you could take it like hey you just
need to impose your will which is
actually what he just said impose your
will on the imperial purpose but
i think he meant them in the way that
you get people to do that by
getting them involved with the plan and
letting them take ownership and letting
you know you're climbing that ladder of
alignment yep that we talk about
yes
and and look if i say hey no jason this
is what we're doing and you're like hey
roger that got it boss i don't agree
with this plan but i'm gonna execute it
we're good like you can be like hey
there's times where you and i might
disagree about something i go hey listen
we don't have time to figure this out
we gotta go and we gotta go now so take
five vehicles and go to the north side
of that build that of that compound and
you're like
got it
that that's okay
like we don't have time to discuss this
now if you were like hey jocko that's a
bad call we shouldn't do that i'd be
like now i'm starting to question myself
well okay what does he see that i don't
see what does he understand that i don't
understand so
can you say listen this is what we got
to do we got to do it now time is of the
essence yes but if you're still getting
pushback there's a problem
you can't overly trust yourself as a
leader i never freaking trust myself
like i'm always thinking what am i what
am i not seeing what does jason see that
i don't see what does echo understand
that i don't understand what pers what
perspective do they have that i don't
have here and here's one of the things
about doing what we we talk about
gettysburg right
and
sure i can learn a lot from
the things that
that chamberlain did
and hancock and these other guys what i
really need to do is pay attention to
when i'm acting like sickles
and just not paying attention and
pushing the line out even though i was
told not to when i'm doing that or
when you know i'm behaving like lee and
i don't understand my subordinates
perspective and i'm giving them obtuse
directions you know and you always want
to identify yourself with the heroes in
any story
where the most growth is going to come
from is where you go wait how am i like
these people
that really screwed this up and how can
i fix that yep
and you will see yourself in
in your past you'll be like oh i know
when i did that
and you'll see it in your present like
oh i think i'm doing that right now and
then hopefully that will prevent you
from making these mistakes in the future
and
truly when you when you walk the grounds
and you start to see what they see
saw and see what they were looking at
and then you get to walk to the other
person's perspective and see oh what
does he mean by that order it's
it's it's very powerful to experience it
and not just hear about it for sure um
he says bernstein attempted a
vindication somewhat on these lines but
too late he prepared an order removing
from command several of his high-ranking
but too little subordinate generals
and made ready to prefer charges against
them for trial by court martial
so after this went down he's like oh
we're gonna fire some people
and
then this but lincoln again interposed
his common sense advice
and the matter was passed over you could
see lincoln just a badass like hey
listen bro
i
i know freaking jason and echo dude do
exactly what you want him to do now you
want to fire him but uh
you're the guy in charge court martial
is a little more than firing him yeah
yeah yeah
what's really cool about his
observations through this battle and
some other battles is it gives you an
insight
to what has made the seal team so
successful and what made it successful
is our ability to debrief stuff
basically where we take off rank we're
like hey what did we do right where what
did we do wrong what were our
shortcomings and he brings that out in
this one and other ones where he's just
laying it out it's like hey
here were some of the issues like
communication obviously is a huge issue
a guy is getting word of something on a
dynamic battlefield that's happening as
it happening then he's giving new orders
and by the time they get back and forth
everything has changed yeah can you
imagine like someone's flanking you
and then you go to tell someone you know
hey hey echo go tell jason that i'm
getting flanked
cool
30 minutes later you get the word that
i'm getting flanked and you say well you
know uh shift left
and echo comes back to me 30 i'm already
done
i'm already flanked it's over i either
did something or i didn't do it but the
whole thing it's so
that's why decentralized command is so
important in all these battles and
knowing and understanding you can tell
when we get into some of these other
battles like how well that worked in
some situations and
how how
you know chamberlain in some cases
kind of decides what he's gonna do
based on
the orders that he thinks are gonna be
the most effective for the situation
that's going down that's another weird
thing you get to at gettysburg which
we're about to talk about but at
gettysburg sometimes the situation and
we go into some good depths on this when
we go out there but
you know one guy takes initiative and it
turns out good and everyone's clapping
him on the back like he's a hero another
guy takes initiative maybe in a little
bit different manner and things go
sideways and everyone calls this guy a
jackass
well
well there's reasons for that and once
we start to talk about the differences
between person a takes initiative and
it's good person b takes initiative and
it's bad
oh
wait wait a second
why was that good here and now it's bad
um i actually have that leadership
strategy and tactics this
first platoon i did i like made a call
even though i was a new guy and my chief
said hey good job three platoons later i
make a call and my oic is like bro what
are you doing like i didn't want to do
that and
you have to dissect why was it good for
me to take initiative here but bad for
me to take initiative here oh not
because the leaders were different it's
because i was doing
i was making wrong assessments
so
[Applause]
all right
gettysburg
through blood and fire at gettysburg by
the way yeah i'm i'm feeling sorry for
anyone that
that doesn't get this book i'm obviously
only reading chunks of it but um
it's awesome
here we go
in a moment the whole core was marching
was in marching order rest rations earth
itself forgotten one thought to be first
on that gettysburg road the iron-faced
veterans were transformed to boys they
insisted on starting out with the colors
flying so that even the knight might
know what manner of men were coming to
redeem the day this is as these guys are
getting my order to gettysburg i kind of
had to
had to talk about that
um
there's a race to little round top
and again there's more detail about the
whole battle and look
we would have to read the whole book to
really paint the picture of what's going
on so
i don't want to get into the game or the
i i don't think i'm skilled enough as a
human to convey the whole battlefield is
unfolding so well if you go watch like a
20 minute video or seven minute video on
gettysburg and understand the scheme of
maneuver you'll be able to put some of
this stuff in context
um
but here we go this is the race to
little round top in another instant a
staff officer from general warren rushed
up to find sykes our core commander to
beg him to send a brigade at least to
seize little round top before the
enemy's surging waves could should
overwhelm it
other supplications were in the air
calling for aid everywhere are vincent
soldierly and self-reliant hearing this
and treaty for round top weighted word
from those superior but taking the
responsibility ordered us to turn and
push for round top at all possible speed
and dashed ahead to study how best to
place us
so there's some decentralized command
happening he like hears hey we got to
take this cool i got it
and then goes up ahead to see all right
once we get up there i'm gonna put the
people in the right position
we broke to that right and rear found a
rude log bridge over plum run and and a
rough farm road leading to the base of
the mountain here as we could we took to
the double quick so these guys run
run to this position so little round top
is a hill it's on the left
flank of the union
which has pretty much taken this ridge
line
to
to stand and fight against the
confederate forces
fast forward a little bit as we neared
the summit of the mountain the shot
raked the crest that we had kept our men
below to save our heads although this
did not wholly avert the visits of
treetops and splinters of rock and iron
while the boulders and clefs and
pitfalls in our path made them seem like
the replica of the evil den across the
sweetly named plum run
and when you go to when you go to
gettysburg you can see this area they
call the devil's den it's just a crazy
outcroppings of rocks and trees it's
it's like the craziest it looks like a
uh a paintball
battlefield like setup thing yeah if
you've been to disneyland that tom
sawyer island where they're all the
boulders and they're just full of caves
yeah that's what it is yeah
these guys are up above that reaching
the southern face of little round top i
found vincent there
with an intense poise and look he said
with a voice of awe as if translating
the tables of the eternal law
i place you here
this is the left of the union line you
understand you are to hold this ground
at all costs
i did understand full well
but had more to learn about costs
the regiment coming up right in front
was put into position by quite an
uncommon order on the right by file into
line both that we should thus be facing
the enemy when we came to a front
and also be ready to commence firing as
fast as each man arrived
this is a rather slow style of formation
but this time it was needful knowing
that we had no support on the left i
dispatched a stalwart company under the
level-headed captain morrell in that
direction with orders to move along up
the valley of our front and left between
us and the eastern base of the great
round top to keep within supporting
distance of us and act as eggs and
cheese of the battle should
require so these guys are getting in
position as basically as fast as they
can sounds like like a peel into
position kind of
yeah
yeah and then the the then pushing those
guys out there across that little valley
sketchy yeah uh but i think that
they must have been there must have been
less trees there and they they had to
have visual
visual eyes on them yeah there there
definitely was
um it's not as wood there's not as wood
as it is today
uh so these guys are on so so
chamberlain and his men are on little
round top
and then their little round top goes
down and then it goes back up on the
other side
and that's the the other side is big
round top and this guy
captain morrell takes a small group of
guys like a dozen guys or something he
runs into those berdan sharpshooters
over there
and
but the the supporting distance you know
for me supporting distance
means that you can shoot
you know we you can help me with your
guns and i can probably i can see you
and hopefully i can yell to you i don't
know if you could yell over all this
noise but
uh supporting distance that's a
doctrinal term
it's like the essence of cover and move
by the way
because hey if you go out there by
yourself and you go too far away well
now you're not any help to us and you're
not neat you're gonna not gonna get any
help from us either
and they they had to have that lineup
what we call line of communications
um where they could at least see
somebody yeah yeah and these guys
probably had some pretty good hand and
arm signals i would think to be able to
communicate i mean even we have pretty
freaking good hand and arm signals
[Applause]
here we go the 20th main regiment had
358 men equipped for duty in the ranks
with 28 officers they were all
well-seasoned soldiers and what is more
well-rounded men body and brain
one somewhat important side note must
have place here in order properly to
appreciate the mental and moral attitude
of the men before us
120 of these men from the second main
were recruits
whom some recruiting officer had led
into the belief that they should be
discharged with their regiment at the
end of its term of service
in their enthusiasm they had not noticed
that they were signing enlistment papers
for quote three years of the war end
quote
and when they had been held in the field
after the discharge of the regiment they
had refused to do military duty and had
been sequestered in a prisoner's camp as
mutineers awaiting court martial so he's
got 120 guys that had signed up hey i'm
gonna go work for the whatever the 13th
main and then
they thought they were going to work
with the 13th main well the 13th main
stands down they fight a bunch of
battles with them too they fight a bunch
of battles but then it stands down and
then they go hey we're oh cool that
regiment stood down we're going home and
they're like no no you signed up for
three years no we signed up with that
regiment yeah then that regiment's done
yeah but you signed up for three years
so now these guys are pissed
on principle
by the way even in ancient times guess
what that recruiters were out there
doing
they're fisting
and the recruiters even back in the day
the recruiters were lying to these
fools getting them in there so these
guys are pissed they're vexed
and
they're waiting court-martial and he's
and so here we go the exigency exigency
of our movement
the last of may had not permitted this
semi-civil treatment and orders from the
secretary of war had directed me to make
these take these men upon my roles and
put them to duty
this made it harder
for
them to accept as they had never
enlisted in this regiment
however
they had been soon brought over to me
under another guard of the 108th
pennsylvan 118th pennsylvanian
with fixed bayonets
with orders to me to take them into my
regiment and quote make them do duty or
shoot them down the moment they refuse
so guards bring these guys over at point
of bayonet
and say hey you got these guys not my
problem anymore this is like the shitty
team guy that's like hey jason i got a
guy for your platoon you want him
um
and he tells them hey take these guys
make him do duty or shoot him
these had been the very words of the
core commander in person the
responsibility i thought gave me some
discretionary power so i had placed
their names on our roles distributed
them by groups to equalize companies and
particularly to break up the esprit de
corps of banded mutineers so that's a
brilliant move he takes him and says
okay you three guys are going this
platoon you four guys are going this
platoon he breaks them up
then i
then i had called them together and
pointed out to them the situation that
they could not be entertained as
civilian guests by me that they were by
authority of the united states on my
roles as soldiers and i should treat
them as soldiers should be treated that
they should lose no rights by obeying
orders and i would see what could be
done for their claim
it is pleasant to record that all but
one or two had gone back
manfully to duty to become some of the
best soldiers in the regiment as i was
to prove this very day so he treated
them with respect he talked to him said
listen i understand you got some claims
i get it but hey if you act like a
soldier i'll have you get my back right
now and i'm have your back
and all but i guess two
stood up and
incredible yeah
that's leadership
by the way the other leader who attacks
them and disparages them has to guide
them at bayonet
this is the thing i get all the time you
know the i always have to bring up the
vietnam draftees and just how you know
some people when people tell me about
whatever group they're working with
it's the millennials it's the union it's
the the the craft people it's the it's
the nurses it's the doc
they take all these groups of people
whoever they are whatever business we're
working with yeah and they're like well
the thing is with the nurses the thing
is with the millennials they factor in
these groups that no this is the worst
group of people ever
right
because they don't want to listen or
they think they deserve this they think
they deserve that
and i was just
my go-to is like
i think the hardest group of human
beings in the his in history
to deal with was the vietnam draftees
because the vietnam draftees
didn't want to be there they didn't
believe in the war and they could die
doing their job
yeah i'm i'm running through my head
right now
guys were drafted in world war ii and
other wars they were drafted but none of
them were as
unpopular as the vietnam and it was you
know it's debatable whether the vietnam
war was an existential threat so that
that like is
and top it off with that the massive
drug problem and all the other issues
that were coming to a head inside the
ranks and then you've got to deal with
that
yeah
and that trumps anybody else's issues
with
unions or nurses or anything else
yeah
it's any group
i i you know nurses teachers uh
you name the group and there's some
leader
not all leaders but there's a bad leader
out there that says well you know the
thing is with our software engineers is
they think they deserve this they say it
about every single group
you know the thing with millennials they
they think oh oh you know the
this this uh gen x folks they think they
built all this so they think everybody
says that's about everyone so here's the
deal
if you were a good leader in vietnam and
you had draftees which you did
you the good leaders loved the draftees
and they had no issue hackworth's one of
them
because i love what he says he's like
they would actually tell me when i was
screwed up yeah
and he's comfortable enough in his own
skin
to be able to have someone telling me
screwed up and go oh okay well let me
see if i am screwed up or instead of
just going home
you know shut up or fire and and and
general mukayama when he was working for
hack said
he i said well what did you think your
draft he said i couldn't tell who was
draftees and who wasn't
i mean come on
treat people with respect
listen to what they have to say
take their input have their back and you
can take guys that are prisoners and
turn them into soldiers that are about
to fight and sacrifice
in the matter of
a dozen hours because he got these guys
like 12 hours before getting to
gettysburg or maybe a little bit longer
but it's a quick turnaround time we're
not talking about months where he's
serenading these prisoners
trying to get them to change their minds
you know what else is amazing is imagine
this you're about to go into combat
and up comes the 118th pennsylvania and
goes hey bro not my problem anymore this
is your problem now
there's a lot of people that say yeah
what are you kidding me i'm not taking
these guys or yay put them over there
lock them to a tree right what i'm not
dealing with this right now instead he
goes okay this is what i got cool i'm
gonna work with it what a what an
awesome attitude
i know i was i was
i would we i definitely took
people in platoons or in the train
tradet where's like hey we got this
issue cool sunrise let me let me let me
work with this dude let me let me figure
out what's going on instead of being
like i don't want him hey man let's
figure out what's going on with this guy
chances are he's probably a halfway
decent dude that just has some issues
going on he's probably going through a
divorce maybe done six back-to-back
deployments i don't know what's going on
but you don't either when i ask you
these questions you don't even know
what's happening with him you're just
telling me he's got a bad attitude why
does he have a bad attitude
like let give him to me give him to me
i put him in charge of cleaning the head
right another example from strategy and
tactics yeah we'll put him in charge of
something yeah well we did he still has
a bad attitude what was it
or cleaning the head cleaning the
bathrooms on the second deck
[Laughter]
let him run a dive
all right
so here we go
i released the prisoners and provost
guards all together and sent them to the
companies all but the drummer boys and
hospital attendants went into the ranks
even the cooks and servants not liable
for such service asked to go in
others whom i knew to be sick or foot
sore and had given a pass to fall out on
the forced marches of the day and night
before came up
now that the battle was on dragging
themselves along on lame and bleeding
feet finding their regiment
and their places
where need is greatest and heart's
truest
think of that for a second
like you just pointed out these guys
didn't even have shoes that were fitted
for left foot or right foot
and they're dragging themselves up to
the meat grinder saying put me in coach
and bleeding feet i forget what the
forced road march was to get here but it
was long it was no joke these guys are
hurting when they show up it's hot
hot was you know it's july july they're
in wool uniforms
the enemy had already turned the third
core left the devil's den was a smoking
crater the plum run gorge was a whirling
maelstrom
one force was charging our advanced
batteries near the wheat field the
flanking force was pressing past the
base of the round tops all rolling
toward us in tumultuous waves it was a
stirring not to say appalling sight here
a whole battery of shot and shell
cutting a ragged chasm through the
series mass flinging men and horses like
drift aside there a rifle volley at
close range with reeling shock hands
tossed in the air muskets dropped with
death's quick relax or clutched with the
last convulsive energy men falling like
grass before the sky others with
manhoods proud calm and rally there a
neat little group kneeling above some
favorite officer slain his intense
spirit still animating the fiery steed
pressing headlon with our empty saddle
to the van
here a defiant regiment of ours broken
slaughtered captured or survivors of
both sides crouching among the rocks for
shelter from the terrible crossfire
where there was no rear
but all advancing all the frenzied force
victors and vanquished each scarcely
knowing which surging and foaming toward
us
death around behind before
and madness everywhere
it's a it's we haven't even gotten to
like the real stress so he's just
showing up yes insane the picture that
he's painting yeah so he's on little
round top now and this is what he's
looking at
just complete and utter chaos and mayhem
[Applause]
and that chaos and mayhem
back to the book it soon reached us
still extending two brigades of hood's
division had attacked texas and alabama
the fourth alabama reached our right the
47th alabama joined and crowded in but
gradually owing to their echelon advance
soon seven companies of this regiment
were in our front
we had all we could stand
my attention was sharply called now here
now there in the thick and smoke
lieutenant nichols a bright officer near
our center ran up to tell me something
queer was going on in his front behind
those engaging us
i sprang forward mounted a great rock in
the midst of his company line and was
soon able to absolve the queer
impression into positive knowledge
thick groups in gray were pushing up
along the smooth dale between the round
tops in a direction to gain our left
flank
there was no mistaking this
if they could hold our attention by a
hot fight in front while they got in
force on that flank it would be bad for
us and our whole defense
how many were coming we could not know
we were rather too busy to send out a
reconnaissance if a strong force should
gain our rear our brigade would be
caught as by a mighty shear blade and
cut and crushed
what would follow it would be easy to
foresee
this must not be our orders to hold that
ground had to be liberally interpreted
that front had to be held that rear
covered
something must be done quickly and
coolly
i called the captains and told them my
tactics to keep the front fire at the
hottest without special regard to its
need or immediate effect and at the same
time as they found opportunity to take
side steps to the left
coming gradually into one rank file
closers and all
then i took the colors with their guard
and placed them at our extreme left
where a great boulder gave token and
support thence bending back at a right
angle the whole body gained ground
leftward and made twice our original
front
we were not long
in doing it
this was a difficult movement to execute
under fire
requiring coolness as well as heat
of rare quality where my officers and
men i shall never cease to admire and
honor them
for what they did in this desperate
crisis
so he had been told told to hold
specific ground
and not give it up
and you know he says what did he say
takes this this liberally
he had to adjust it because he
understood the intent was to make sure
that little round top got held not just
the front but little round top as a
whole so he had to adjust from just
facing one direction
to
where he's got troops that are facing
not just in front of him but also to his
left flank and then a little bit behind
him because he saw that the
the confederates were making a move
trying to flank
meantime the tremendous blow of the
fourth and fifth texas struck the right
of our brigade
and our
16th michigan reeled and staggered back
under the shock confusion followed
vincent felt that all was lost unless
the very gods should intervene
sword aloft and face a flame he rushed
in among the broken companies in
desperate effort to rally them man by
man
by sheer force of his superb personality
he restored a portion of his line and
was urging up the rest don't yield an
inch now men or all is lost he cried
when an answering volley scorched the
very faces of the men and vincent's soul
went up in a chariot of fire
and that agonizing moment
came tearing up the 140th new york
gallant o'rourke at the head not waiting
to load a musket or form a line they
sprang forward into that turmoil
met by a withering volley that killed
its fine young colonel and laid low many
of his intrepid officers and a hundred
of his men this splendid regiment as by
a providence
we may well call divine saved us all in
that moment of threatened doom
to add a tragic splendor to this dark
scene in the midst of it all the
indomitable hazlitt was trying to get
his guns 10 pounder rifled parrots up to
a working place on a small summit close
beyond finally he was obliged to take
his horses entirely off and lift his
guns by hand and hand spike up the
craggy steep once he launched death and
defiance wide and far around
the roar of all this tumult reached us
meanwhile on the left and heightened the
intensity of our resolve
meanwhile the flanking column worked
around to our left and was joined with
those before us in a fierce assault
which lasted with increasing fury for an
intense hour
the two lines met and broke and mingled
and the shock the crush of musketry gave
way to cuts and thrusts grappling and
wrestlings
the edge of the conflict swayed to and
fro with wild whirlpools and eddies at
times i saw around me more of the enemy
than of my own men gaps opening
swallowing closing again with sharp
convulsive energy squads of stalwart men
who had cut their way through us
disappearing as if translated
all around strange
mingled roar shouts of defiance rally
and desperation and underneath murmured
entry uh and stifled moans gasping
prayers snatches of sabbath song
whispers of love names everywhere men
torn and broken staggering creeping
quivering on the earth and dead faces
with strangely fixed eyes staring stark
into the sky
things which cannot be told nor dreamed
how men held on each one knows not i
but manhood commands admiration
there was one fine young fellow who had
been cut down early in the fight with a
ghastly wound across his forehead and
who i thought might possibly be saved
with prompt attention
so i sent him back to our little field
hospital at least to die in peace
within a half an hour
in a desperate rally i saw that noble
youth amidst the rolling smoke as an
apparition from the dead with bloody
bandage for the only covering of his
head in the thick of the fight high born
and pressing on that they shall see
death no more
so
you've got this
just incredibly intense assault on this
hill
you've got the hill just about to be
overrun when this guy vincent strong
vincent
rallies his troops and holds the line
and then dies and then as right as the
line's about to get broken again
o'rourke
from the 140th new york brings his
troops up same things able to hold the
line
they ain't they don't even get a chance
to load their muskets they're just
injured just dive into the fight
continues on
when that mad carnival lulled from some
strange instinct in human nature and
without any reason in the situation that
can be seen when the battling edges drew
asunder there stood our little line
groups and gaps notched like saw teeth
but sharp as steel
tempered in infernal heats like a magic
sword of the goths
we were up on the appointed and
entrusted line
we had held the ground at all costs
but now that the smoke dissolved we saw
our dead and wounded all out in front of
us mingled with more of the enemy they
were scattered all the way down to the
very feet of the baffled hostile line
now rallying in low shrubbery for a new
onset
we could not wait for this they knew our
weakness now and they were gathering
force no place for tactics now the
appeal to must be to primal instincts of
human nature so they go through this
they hold the line barely
and as the smart smoke begins to clear
they're looking at over the field down
the hill and they see all their wounded
a bunch of enemy wounded and dead
and then they see the enemy
starting to
gather and muster for yet another
attack
continuing on first it was to gather our
wounded this is the human instinct he's
talking about first it was to gather our
human
our wounded
and bear them to the sheltered lawn for
saving life or peace
in dying the dead too
that not even our feet should do them
dishonor in the coming encounter
then such is heavenly human pity
the wounded of our country's foes
brothers in blood for us now
so far from other caring born like
refugee and sucker by the drummer boys
who'd become angels of the field
so they go out and start trying to help
they're dead they're wounded and then
the confederate soldier wounded
in this lull i took a turn over the
dismal field to see what could be done
for the living in ranks or recumbent
and came upon a manly form and face i
well remembered he was a sergeant
earlier in the field of antietam and of
frederickberg
and for refusing to perform some menial
personal service for a bullying
quartermaster in winter camp was reduced
to the ranks by a commander who had not
carefully investigated the case
it was a degradation and the injustice
of it wrankled in his highborne spirit
but his well-bred pride would not allow
him to ask for justice as a favor i had
kept
this in mind for early action
now he was lying there stretched on an
open front so what he's just said is
he's got this guy that he remembers that
fought well at antietam and fraud at
fredericksburg and he had
he was probably just a freaking btf tony
type dude that was just a
freaking badass and somebody told him to
do some dumb [__] he's like i'm not
doing that
and he gets reduced in rank
now he was lying there stretched out an
open front where a brave stand had been
made face to the sky a great bullet hole
in the middle of his breast from which
he had loosened his closing clothing to
ease the breathing
and the rich blood was pouring in a
stream
i bent down over him
his face lightened his lips moved
but i spoke first my dear boy it's gone
hard for you
you shall be cared for
he whispered tell my mother i did not
die a coward
it was the prayer of home bred manhood
poured out with his lifeblood
i knew and answered him
you die a sergeant
i promote you for your faithful service
and noble courage on the field of
gettysburg
this was all he wanted
no word more
i'd i had him born from the field
but his high spirit had passed to its
place
it is needless to add that as soon as a
piece of parchment could be found after
that battle a warrant was made out
promoting
george washington buck
to sergeant
the silence and the doubt of the
momentary low were quickly dispelled so
all that took place while there was a
lull in the fire
the 47th alabama had rallied to our
right
we were enveloped in fire
and sure to be overwhelmed in fact when
the great surge struck us already i
could see the bold flankers on their
right darting out and creeping catlike
under the smoke to gain our left thrown
back as it was
it was for us then once for all our thin
line was broken and the enemy were in
the rear of the whole round top defense
infantry artillery humanity itself with
the round top and the day theirs
now too our fire was slackening our last
rounds of shot had been fired what i had
sent for could not get to us i saw the
faces of my men one after the other
when they had fired their last cartridge
turn anxiously toward mine for a moment
then square to the front again
to the front for them late death to the
rear what they would die to save
my thought was running deep
i was combining the elements of a
forlorn hope and it just communicated
this to captain spear when
a captain spear of the wheeling flank on
which the initiative was to fall
just then
brave warm-hearted lieutenant melcher of
the color company whose captain and
nearly half of his men were down came up
and asked if he might take his company
and go forward to pick up one or two of
his men left wounded on the field and
bring them in before the enemy got too
near
this would be a most hazardous move in
itself
and in this desperate moment we could
not break the line but i admired him
with a glance
he understood i answered yes sir in a
moment i am about to order a charge
so they're almost out of bullets
that's a that's a freaking crazy thought
as you're in command and as guys run out
of bullets they look at you like
i'm out
and then they look back to the
front and this kid comes up saying hey
boss can i go out there and recover some
of my wounded guys before the enemy gets
too close
and he knows he can't give that order
but he says well
in a moment
not a moment was about to be lost five
minutes more of such defensive and the
last roll call would sound for us
desperate as the chances were there was
nothing for it but to take the offensive
i stepped to the
colors the men turned toward me
one word was enough bayonet it caught
like fire and swept along the ranks the
men took it up with a shout one could
not say whether it was from the pit or
the song of the morning star
it was vain to order forward no mortal
could have heard it in the mighty
hasanah that was
winging the sky
nor would he wait to hear it
there are things still of the first
creation whose seed is in itself
the grading clash of steel and fixing
bayonets told its own story
the color
rose in front the whole line quivered
for the start the edge of the left wing
rippled swung tossed among the rocks
straightened changed curve from scimitar
to sickle shape and down the bristling
arches swooped down upon the seared host
down into the face of half a thousand
two hundred men
so it's about a thousand or so sorry
it's about 500 people against 200
and all he had to say was bayonet
that imagery is just incredible
his description of it more alliteration
it's just
in
sane he says it was a great right wheel
our left swung first the advancing foe
stopped tried to make a stand amidst the
trees and boulders but the frenzied
bayonets
pressing through every space forced a
constant settling to the rear moral
moril
with his detached company and the
remnants of our valorous sharpshooters
who had held the enemy so long in check
on the slopes of the great round top now
fell upon the flank of the retiring
crowd and it turned into full retreat
sung amidst the crags of the great round
top so that's lucky
as the confederate soldiers are starting
to fall back now they're
now who's on their flank but merrell and
the guys that had gone up on the on the
big round top
at the first dash the commanding officer
i happened to confront so this is as
this is going down at the first dash the
commanding officer i happen to confront
coming on fiercely sword in one hand and
big navy revolver on the other fires one
barrel almost in my face
but seeing the quick saber point at his
throat throat reverses arms gives sword
and pistol into my hands and yields
himself a prisoner
i took him at his word but could not
give him further attention i passed him
over the custom custody of a brave
sergeant at my side to whom i gave the
sword as an emblem of his authority but
kept the pistol with its loaded barrels
which i thought might come in handy soon
as indeed it did
ranks were broken many retired before us
somewhat hastily some threw their
muskets to the ground even loaded sunk
on their knees threw up their hands
calling out we surrender don't kill us
as if we wanted to do that we kill only
to resist killing
and these were manly men
whom we could befriend and by no means
kill if they came our way in peace and
goodwill
charging right through and over these we
struck the second line to the 47th
alabama doing their best to stand but
offering little resistance the
lieutenant colonel as i passed and a
fine gentleman was the lieutenant bulger
introduced himself as my prisoner
and as he was wounded i had him cared
for as best we could
still swinging to the right as the great
gate on its hinges we swept the front
clean of assailants
so that's it i mean that's the that's
the famous charge bayonet charge from
little round top
down little round top and those guys
from the alabama
have been running all day
in
wool uniforms
they were out of water they hadn't had
water in hours they they had a couple
guys trying to go and try and find water
and they got run up and they're just
this
just it's an incredible
clash
and the way
chamberlain talks about this and he
talks about that we could be friends
with these guys
if we weren't fighting and he keeps that
in his mind it's something that um
i was not able to do on the battlefield
i had a little bit of hatred in my heart
when i went to war but this guy
he's at peace
the whole time and i think that's what
what makes him such
that is what makes him such an
incredible leader
and person yeah
to go through that to lose all all these
guys
and still as soon as these guys
surrender be like yep okay i'll treat
you fair enough yep
i mean i think that's definitely easier
when it's you know you're fighting
america other americans i mean i guess
they were confederates but
um you know you have these guys had so
much in common with
you know when we
when we fight all of a sudden we're
fighting against a person with a
different language a person with a
different culture
person from a different country
it's a slippier slope it's weird it's
way slightly easier way slippery to
start to fall into that stuff which is
which is not the best way to do it
because when the the next thing that you
the next step that you're on when you go
down there is to lose respect for the
enemy and then you get complacent and
that complacency always comes back to
bite you yep
this is going forward a little bit
he has to get them to stop
because they're charging and they're
too much he says too much motivation he
says it was no light task to get our men
to stop
they were under the momentum of their
deed they thought they were on the road
to richmond
they had to be reasoned with persuaded
but at last faced about and marched back
to that dedicated crest with swelling
hearts
not without sad interest in service was
the return
for many of the wounded had to be
gathered up
there was a burden too of the living
nearly 400 prisoners remained in our
hands two for every man of ours
at nine o'clock the next morning we were
withdrawn being relieved by our first
brigade
but we were sent to support anything
but a place of rest our new position was
in support of hancock's troops near the
left center of the union line which
proved to be the point
aimed at by pickett's charge that
afternoon
so they they kind of said hey look these
guys just made a stand on little round
top
and they lost a bunch of guys
and we're going to give them a little
breather so instead of putting them out
on a flank again we're going to bring
them right into the center of the union
line where they're probably not you know
probably not going to see anything
we should be okay
and that ends up being the spot where
pickett's charge literally takes place
and unless i'm mistaken the guy that
makes it the far from furthest from the
confederates
was hancock's best man in his wedding
yeah yeah
incredible
yeah they have that they have that
monument the high water the high water
mark of where the confederacy made it to
they have a thing this is where this guy
made it to the furthest north
he says it was certainly a narrow chance
for us and for the roundtops
had we not used up our ammunition and
had we continued to meet the enemy
musket to musket this give and take
would have soon finished us by reason of
the enemy superior numbers that's an
incredible debrief point
so he's saying look if we would have had
enough ammunition and we would have just
sat there and trade shots with them they
had more people so eventually they would
have they would have taken us they had
what 500 people we had 200. we don't
just trade war of attrition we're going
to lose violence of action right
he just deployed violence of action the
college professor understood it and
that's like
that's what we were always taught yeah
on day one in the seal teams yeah
there's a that's what we get taught we
get taught speed surprise and violence
of action
there was a vietnam vet that had broken
service obviously and he came back in
the teams um
and did a platoon chief slot
man i think he he was almost 50 when he
did a platoon chief slot
and i remember
i was in the training cell we were
running an operation for him and we had
kind of a big target and they were set
up
and he was briefing his geyser doing a
little sand table
before they were getting ready i was
land grading them they're getting ready
to go hit the target and he goes
boys
there's a lot to be said for violence of
action let's get online and mow this
target down
and they did it
was so impressive
oh that's so good
um
he goes on with a little bit more
debrief or had the 15th alabama alabama
continued their onset not regarding our
preposterous demonstrations they would
have walked over our bodies to their
victory
or still again if one more confederate
regiment had come up on our flank we
must have been rolled into a zero figure
and swallowed up in the envelopment
it was a
psychological success
a miracle in the scheme of military
science that's an interesting way to
describe it a psychological success you
you definitely hear those
that the bayonet is a psychological
weapon
there you go
those brave alabama fellows none braver
or better in either army
were victims of a surprise
of their quick and mobile imagination
damn
like it got to him in that split second
yep
continues on here we had gone up the
round top slopes to bid farewell to our
dead
we found them there on the sheltered
lawn where we had laid them on the
velvet moss fringed by low cedars that
veiled the place with peace and beauty
i rode up near
and flinging the rain upon my horse's
neck dismounted to bend over
them for a soldier's farewell there they
lay
side by side with touch of elbow still
brave bronzed faces where the where the
last thought was written
manly resolution heroic self-giving
divine reconciliation
or where on some young face the sweet
mother look had come out under death's
soft whisper
we buried them there in a grave alas too
wide on the sunny side of a great rock
eternal witnesses of their worth
the rock and the sun
rude headboards made of ammunition boxes
rudely carved under tear-dimmed eyes
marked and named each grave
and told each home
he goes on to say i thought of those
other noble men of every type commanders
all
who bore their wounds so bravely many to
meet their end on later fields and those
whose true hearts further high trust
were to be laid
nor did i forget those others whether
their names are written on the scrolls
of honor and fame or their dust left on
some far field and nameless here
nameless never to me nor nameless i
trust in god where they are tonight
i sat there alone on the storied crest
till the sun went down as it did over
the misty hills and the darkness crept
up the slopes till from all earthly
sight i was buried with those before
but oh what radiant companionship rose
around what steadfast ranks of power
what bearing of heroic souls
oh the glory that beamed through those
nights and days nobody will ever know it
here
i am sorry most of all for that
the proud young valor that rose above
the mortal
and then at last
was mortal after all
so there's gettysburg
um
and what's crazy is you think that
that's gettysburg
like um epic heroic
beyond mythical scenario that unfolded
in real time for this guy and for his
troops
and then what do they do
march
because it's not over
[Applause]
going forward now to petersburg
and again get this book there's so much
detail in here that i'm not covering
here we'll do an audio book
just randomly checking with echo charles
my my editor over here get to do a light
main accent oh that'd be good wouldn't
it
oh sure
um man you're right i should have been
doing a down easter this whole time
would he have talked like that though
that's hard to say it certainly doesn't
seem like it um
but you know we could have
you know it's a very subtle it can be
subtle it could be just a little bit
would have been subtle
um
so here we go to petersburg because i i
don't know what else to tell you about
gettysburg other than
going if you get the chance to go there
go there
and don't rush
and take your time
and
you will have a spiritual experience
that's what i'm going to tell you about
about gettysburg
and and by the way that's one story
because there's so many things like
everywhere you look at gettysburg
there's there's little round top style
battles that are just
make or breaking
the future of our country yep
going back to the book when on the
evening of june 17th under the sharp
attack of our second and ninth chord the
enemy drew in the outer line of their
defenses they left on an outlying crest
near the deep cut of the norfolk radar
railroad and advanced artillery post
commanding the approaches from our side
to the fortifications at reeves salient
from this position early on the 18th
they opened a strong slant fire on our
division then drawn up for an assault in
our immediate front
north of the railroad
our attack was thus delayed while our
own batteries were getting into position
to support this assault so we're going
into an assault
our line however was held in place
perhaps to take the enemy's attention
from the movement of our guns cover move
is happening
this raking fire along our ranks was
very trying to the nerves
which is a very mild way of saying
things
freaking raking fire from cannons is
trying to our nerves as well as to our
judgment of the tactics which held us
there
when we were not allowed to move forward
nor hit back
i am not saying to get back so he's not
saying he wanted to leave he said he
wanted to fight but he's getting told no
no hold that you got hey we're getting
we're getting freaking raked with fire
here just hold what you got
our men were going down fast and for no
good that we could see it was therefore
a welcome piece of information when our
core commander came along with the
euphemism statement that this was quote
very annoying end quote
which remark prefaced the suave inquiry
if i thought i could carry that position
i understood the purport of the mild
inquiry thought indeed was required but
the meeting was action so
let me translate that for you
they're they're getting raked with fire
this commander comes up and says this is
annoying he's like yeah no [__]
and he says do you think you could you
know you could assault that position
and the the what did he say the uh he
understood the that what that inquiry
meant was like hey man
can you make this [__] happen
and he knew that the meaning was action
so he says recon ordering the situation
i could see no likelihood of being able
to hold this place for long nor my
judgment was of importance to hold now
that the batteries were dislodged
which had annoyed our troops in the
designed assault moreover i discovered
that the position was completely
commanded by the enemy's main works at
the salient three or four hundred yards
in our front were plainly seen several
strong earth works
with 12 or 15 guns so disposed
as to deliver a smashing crossfire over
the ground between us
and just across the plank road was a
large fort with heavy guns ready to
sweep the crest we were occupying
between these works was a solid
entrenched infantry line of at least 3
000 men
we were a mile away from the rest of the
army and i prepared to quote take care
of myself i hurried up three batteries
entrusted to me running up the guns
up under the cover of the crest leveling
slight platforms on the hither slope so
that the men could work their guns
taking advantage of their recoil at
discharge to reload and then easily run
them up again the muzzles lying in the
grass
all as yet unperceived by the enemy and
made them ready for what might happen
this
position would be of use in case of a
general assault by our army and this is
what i looked for
they're in a freaking hard situation i
mean that's what this is spelling out at
this juncture what was my astonishment
at receiving a verbal order through a
staff officer personally unknown to me
directing me in the name of
quote the general commanding end quote
to assault the enemy's main works in my
front with my brigade
so the reason i kind of had to set up
some of that military stuff there
was was because about what because of
what's about to happen so he's standing
there he sees this is like a really
tough situation there's 3 000 people
they got flanking guns they're gonna be
in a bad way and this freaking random
guy that he's never seen before says hey
the general commanding says assault
frontal assault
he says this
this was certainly a compliment to my
six splendid regiments
but i think you will justify my
astonishment as well as my backhanded
courage and recklessness of personal
consequences in presuming to send back
to the general a written statement of
the situation with the opinion that that
position could not be carried with a
single brigade even of gettysburg
veterans
so he sends back to the general hey bro
uh no that doesn't sound like a good
idea like me by myself with my regiments
is not gonna make this happen
grant general grant grant had lost all
patience that morning and his chief
subordinates were excited and flurried
in a manner i had not seen before
[Laughter]
i however received a courteous answer
saying that the whole army would join in
on my right
but the single brigade was to make the
assault
and prove the prophecy
and the prophecy here is that grant's
not listening
so he gives push back and says hey i'm
telling you
this isn't going to work
and this is another thing we saw at
gettysburg where
uh
longstreet was saying hey we don't want
to assault the union line right here
it's not a good call and generally he's
like no we're doing it oh no it was it
was he was trying to set up the flanking
maneuver generally he wasn't listening
he pushed back twice yeah pushed back
twice grants the same thing here he you
got
you got freaking chamberlain saying hey
bro i wrote you a note
i don't think we could take this with a
single brigade even of gettysburg
veterans
grant had lost all patience that morning
and his chief supporters were excited
and flurried in a manner i had not seen
before
this is almost i wonder if that's as
funny to people that don't understand
what a staff officer is like in the
military and how they freak out when the
senior leadership says we need to make
this happen how do we make this happen
we have to make this happen
it gets worse too every level that it
calms down it's magnified yep yep and
less listening and more telling yeah
[Applause]
so he says in such an assault musketry
was not to be thought of it must be a
storm of cannonade
a rush of infantry with pieces at the
shoulder
over the works and banned at the enemy
at their guns it was desperate deadly
business the bugler sounded the charge
under that storm of fire the earth flew
into the air men went down like sky
swept grain a wall of smoke veiled the
front i thought it necessary to lead the
charge with full staff following but in
10 minutes not a man was left mounted
my staff were scattered my flag bearer
shot dead my own horse down to cheer and
guide the men where no voice could be
heard nor rank distinguished i picked up
the flag and bore it aloft till close
upon the enemy's works a mini ball cut
me through and the red cross came down
to the reddened
riddled earth
so the red cross is is the their their
symbol and there's they call it colors a
lot
um but this is the flag of these various
unions sometimes they're talking about
the american flag sometimes they talk
about the confederate flags have the
same thing
but
this maltese cross looks like an iron
cross kind of that's their that's what
they have at the 20th main
um
and it's important to note
that these flags
they were very
representative of like the pride and
honor of the unit but beyond that
they were
like a signaling device yeah it's
communication it's communication that
like hey here's where we're at we are
going forward so if the flag goes down
it's a signal that we're not going
forward if the flag is up and going
forward it's a signal that we're going
for if you take the enemy's flag it's a
signal to the enemy that you just got
your ass handed to you and now we're
winning so that flag is is
much
more kind of uh it's not just symbolic i
should say it's hugely symbolic and it's
functional it's totally functional
so when they talk about these scenes and
there's plenty of scenes where you're
gonna see the colors the flags come into
play this is one of them
he sees that he can't even pass any word
there's no word to pass no one can hear
him there's too much noise too much
chaos so he personally runs grabs the
flag
and charges forward
and then he gets cut then he gets shot
he says i saw my men rush past me to the
very muscles of the gun then torn in
pieces and trickling back the enemy
rushing out beyond our left to flank our
batteries on the crest behind us i had
only strength to send two broken
regiments to support the batteries
before i saw that all else was lost
in the midst of this turmoil i lay half
buried by clods of turnip or earth for
an hour
when the shrouding smoke lifting i was
born from the field by some of major
bigelow's men of the ninth massachusetts
battery on the crest
when you picture
that field
air and earth cross cut with thick
flying hitting plunging burying bursting
missiles you will not wonder
that we did not succeed in bayoneting
the enemy at their guns inside their
works
you will rather wonder that some of my
men got near enough to fall within 20
feet of them
bigelow's a beast too he's another one
that we talk about at gettysburg yeah
and it's just it's it's incredible where
he like it boggles my mind
that he he gets shot in the pelvis
essentially and this is this you know
civil war
and he survives
and what do we know he's going to be
back out on the field fighting in like
six months yeah this um
so what happens here
so he's he's he has to leave the field
because he's severely wounded
um and at petersburg it begins nine
months of trench wharf basically of
trench warfare
they call it a siege but it's it's more
like just a prolonged battle
there's 125 000 union soldiers around
petersburg there's 60 000 confederates
trying to hold it
between the two of them
they take about 50 casualties over this
period
you're starting to see some breakdown in
the confederate side
like 25 000 confederate desertions
so that's what's going on meanwhile
while that's happening
uh here's what's going on with
chamberlain and this is this is actually
taken from
a
sort of a memorial
yeah it's like a eulogy or a memorial
art it's in memoriam it's a it's an
article
basically
and it says
at petersburg on the 18th of june he led
an attack on a strong position from
which a heavy artillery fire was
directed
on his advance now listen before we just
jump into this
reminder
here you this is just a classic case
leadership situation
you've got a trusted commander proven
leader by the way a medal of honor
recipient that just freaking led the the
holding of the round tops what maybe a
year but prior this guy is respected and
they went to multiple battles in between
so here he is and he's saying hey boss i
don't think this is a good idea
and you say shut up and go and this is
the result
so when your subordinates are pushing
back
don't think that you're right and
they're wrong
maybe think that they're right and
you're wrong is there a chance you're
right maybe but where's grant where's
grant right now i don't know where he is
he's probably in the rear somewhere with
the gear
you know he's in the rear with the gear
i'm out here on the front line i'm
observing the enemy positions i can see
how they're laid up i understand the
terrain way better than grant does and
now he's telling me no you know what you
shut up in charge don't worry the army's
going to have your back
bro
no
let's not do that
by the way if there was some reason
and i can articulate if i say hey jason
i want you to assault this thing hey
boss doesn't look like a good idea and i
say hey the reason i'm having you
assault that is because as you assault
that we're actually sending some troops
over here to this other position and
that's our main objective and you go got
it
if you can articulate that okay
but if you can't even articulate a
reason other than hey shut up and do
what i told you that's probably not a
good indication if your best defense
in an argument is to say shut up and do
what i told you that's probably an
indication that you don't have a good
argument because you're probably wrong
so this is the kind of lessons that we
can learn from a leader
and you know what chamberlain here's a
discredit to chamberlain
hey i'm not going
hey well i'm not doing this it doesn't
make any sense i'm gonna go talk to
grant i'm leaving right now could he
have pushed back harder he sent one note
could he have pushed back hard he
thought that the army was actually
coming in on the right true
i mean if he if he has a relationship
with grant and he's like okay i buy that
there maybe they're coming in and he's
got a bigger plan for me and that's
probably why
yeah and that seemed to gratify him that
okay if you're gonna hit them with the
you know just like i just said to you if
like hey jason you need assault that
you're like hey bro it doesn't seem like
a good idea and i say yeah but don't
worry i'm gonna get your flank over here
and we're gonna run them up and you go
cool got it because now you know that
you're gonna have to
commence the assault make some progress
but then you're gonna get relief very
quickly and we're gonna have the upper
hand very quickly so now you understand
it and it makes sense so yeah maybe
maybe that was the case
what we can learn from that is there's a
time to push back
and there's a time to push back hard
there's a time to
[Music]
maybe ask questions ask earnest
questions um
and
either way there's there you're you're
losing when you push back there's a way
to push back to
that you're because you're going to lose
capital with the leadership capital with
the person yes and if i tell you to shut
up and do something i'm losing a ton of
leadership capital too and you have to
realize that so two things are important
one is make sure that you're building up
leadership capital with everybody around
you so that you can actually
make withdrawals on that bank account
yeah because you built it up you know
what's weird is i just kind of like left
myself out in in the air i left my flank
out i said there's a time to push back
and there's a and i i was like wait
because to me there's always a time to
push back there's oh if you're telling
me to do something stupid now look if
we're in a fire fight and you look at me
and you say hey jocko get in that
building over there
i'm gonna do it unless i see something
crazy right i'm going to do it i'm not
going to push back then because we're
we're at the moment of truth right
those moments are very rare
they're very very rare
where
i we i have to just trust you now look
we built trust over time so if you tell
me take that building
i know you're telling it to me for a
good reason
so
i guess there's a time to push back i
guess the other the other
part of that is there's a time to make
sure you understand the bigger picture
because you either have to push back or
you ask the question say wait a second
jocko why do you want me to assault that
building it doesn't make any sense and i
say here's why because as you salt that
building we're going to commence these
other operations it's going to keep the
enemy distracted and then we're going to
have the upper hand and you go ok cool
got it so there's a time to push back
there's a time to check yourself and
make sure you understand the bigger
picture yourself
and if there's no bigger picture the
bigger picture doesn't make sense then
maybe you have to say look i'm not doing
this on the battlefield though
everybody's a chess piece
and it may be that you're gonna
you your chess piece is getting taken
and that's probably what he realizes
like okay well he told me they're coming
from the right and this is lousy for us
but they're willing to make that
sacrifice
um it's it's really difficult to parse
apart yeah the
it is difficult to parse apart i mean we
could probably find more research and
get more just more information behind
the decision-making process but the
lesson is very clear
and look you're right there's times
where
especially in an all-out war like this
hey this chess piece just like in chess
literally sometimes you move the knight
and it gets taken by the bishop but now
the bishop is in a blocked position so
you made the good move you sat there are
times in battle where that happens i
mean when you look at d-day
some of those
initial people hitting the beaches
they were they were in a huge situation
to be sacrificed that's what was about
to happen look were they suicide no not
quite but damn
that should be very well they're telling
him to hold the
the left flank uh on little rounds
potted at all hazards but that needs no
explanation right yeah that needs no
explanation hey you didn't even need to
ask why oh this is where on the that's
what he vincent says to him you're on
the extreme left do you understand he's
like yes i understand i know what that
means that means if i go
we if i fall we all
fall um
but that pushback thing is so important
such an important part of leadership
you know the the
the story i talk about dichotomy of
leadership or maybe it's extreme
ownership but push yeah it was a
dichotomy it's like pushing back when
they when my leadership told me you have
to take this many iraqis with you
there's a ratio and i said hey that
doesn't make sense and my leadership
said cool jocko thank you for telling us
because i articulated to them what the
scenario was and you hadn't been pushing
and that's what i was talking about with
the leadership capital you weren't
pushing back all the time and we need
more rental cars on this next trip
hey
uh you know this this or that you're
just like roger that all the dumb stuff
you're just knocking it out yeah oh yeah
we got administrative stuff cool easy
we'll do it and so
the only and this is the mistake people
make with the push and back is they're
pushing back all the time on stuff that
doesn't matter and then it
undercuts them when it actually does
matter and yeah i mean you were in my
freaking sister task unit and so you saw
me doing that kind of stuff like hey
roger that yup got it yep
leaning into it yeah
we'll we'll handle that yeah no factor
and that's how i was able to build up
that leadership capital yes
so that when the pushback mattered i got
listened to which is important
it's shocking that you got chamberlain
as your guy that's pushing back on you
and you're like don't worry about it
so like i said
this
this battle where petersburg in battle
petersburg where joshua chamberlain gets
wounded it ends up in nine months of
trench warfare um
what's he doing during that time go into
this memorial piece that was written
about him at petersburg on the 18th of
july he led an attack on a strong
position from which
a heavy artillery fire was directed on
his advance many of his men were swept
down and chamberlain's horse was killed
by a shell the attack was pushed with
vigor and while leading it on foot
chamberlain fell
shot through by a ball which passed
through the body from hip to hip
severing arteries and fracturing bones
he was carried from the field and taken
to a hospital in annapolis
where for two months
he lay at the point of death
after the general had been taken to the
field hospital
the regular surgeon in charge declared
the case hopeless
companion a.o shaw
surgeon of the 20th maine after an
exhausting day's labor rode through the
woods at night and finding the general
remained with him watching and caring
for him and performing a surgical
operation he found necessary until his
patient seemed out of immediate danger
his friends who were cognizant of the
case have always felt general
chamberlain's life was saved by dr
shaw's skill and faithfulness
in his last illness dr shaw attended his
old chief with the same faithfulness he
had shown in caring for him so many
years before at the end of five months
and before he could mount a horse or
walk a hundred yards chamberlain resumed
command of his brigade before he was
taken from the field he was assured of
his promotion after his arrival at
annapolis he received a telegram as
follows
to lieutenant colonel joshua chamberlain
20th main infantry
special order number 39 first
colonel j l chamberlain 20th main
infantry volunteers for meritorious and
efficient services on the field of
battle and especially for gallant
conduct in leading his brigade against
the enemy at petersburg on the 18th in
which he was seriously wounded hereby in
pursuance of the authority of the
secretary of war is appointed brigadier
general of the u.s volunteers to rank as
such from the 18th day of june 1864
subject to the approval of the president
that's signed by ulysses s grant
this is the only instance in the war of
promotion on the battlefield
the terrible wound received on the 18th
of june 1864 caused him suffering
throughout his life and at intervals
incapacitated him for work of any kind
resuming his command under conditions
that would have amply excused him from
active service he was at once employed
in operations along the weldon railroad
road
his condition was so severely affected
by the hardships of duty
and the inclemency of the weather that
at the end of the month his core
commander insisted on his going north
for treatment while recuperating he
declined many offers of attractive
positions in civil life after a month in
the care of surgeons he stole away from
them and leaving his room for the first
time made the painful journey to the
front and took command of a new brigade
composed of new york and pennsylvania
regiments
bro
you folks from maine
i am in awe at your tenacity and vigor
it's freaking awesome
you know
so
we're approaching two hours deep right
now i'm thinking um
we
break now and um
and pick it up with another podcast
we'll be picking it up as he gets back
he gets back to the military operations
on white oak
road
so well
so much stuff to talk about here um hey
look if you're
interested in this stuff we do we do
this
review of the battlefield of battlefield
review
the next one that we're doing in
gettysburg is may
11th and 12th you actually get there on
the 10th or may
13th and 14th that's at gettysburg
uh
we're there for two days we spend so we
do we basically do two iterations of it
back to back
i could do a hundred iterations back to
back of it
uh
and actually after that we're doing in
august
august 16th and 17th and then august
18th and 19th we're doing little bighorn
which we've covered on the podcast that
battle and some of the people that
fought there we're gonna do it we should
do another one
we'll do a podcast about about
do podcasts about crazy horse
um
but if you want to come to those things
go to ashlandfront.com that's where we
that's where we
yeah and look at events so that's what's
up
echo yes
quiet today
just taking it all in it's an elevated
how hard is it to listen when i'm
reading this stuff
well depends on what you mean by heart
but yeah like you
i realized that even though i was like
oh this guy's such a great writer then i
read it out loud and i i'm kind of
translating it a little bit yeah you
know yeah it's probably needed yes okay
yeah so even even like you get even a
guy nowadays right you know you get
these guys they like to use big words on
purpose you know to sound smart and you
know whatever
whatever um
even then you find your brain like okay
he just said this and you're
trying to essentially it's a form of
translation essentially that's kind of
what it was like yeah actually it was a
lot of what it was like yeah i felt like
that i i
i was doing that and i was doing that
naturally i hadn't planned to do that at
all
and i probably should have prepared a
little bit more to
say hey here's what you're about to hear
because that's the same thing that
happens with
i hate to say it speaking of trying to
sound smart but like when you read
shakespeare if you don't know
what's happening and you just read it
it's a different language it's close to
middle english so it's kind of a
different language
and then once you know what it means and
what those words mean and why their
sentences are formatted a certain way
you go oh wow there's so much more
meaning behind these things and i think
that's probably the case with this book
obviously not to the extent that
shakespeare is but to say oh what does
that actually mean
and then read it again and listen to it
again and say damn
that's an incredible piece of writing
it's like jumping into a cold swimming
pool yeah it's a little bit weird for a
little bit and then you get used to it
you're like oh okay i get it this is
this is good um
or getting used to like cormac mccarthy
writing without any
punctuation punctuation marks and it
just takes you a second and then you get
used to it the weird thing about cormac
mccarthy is his styles between books is
so radically different i think the best
example that being the road
and then and then blood meridian like
when you read the road that is a
straightforward book it's kind of what i
leaned towards in final spin yeah was
just like i don't like a screenplay yeah
and and then and i think he i think he
wrote the purpose yeah i think he wrote
it with some intention of screenplay but
then when you read blood meridian you
need a dictionary
on hand like no unless you're uh
a doctor
a botanist
a a history professor and you know
and a religious um you know
minister you're gonna miss a bunch of
stuff in there i mean just the oh yeah
and also a geologist because he's got
weird rocks he's talking about and
freaking like you gotta have a
a dictionary on standby yeah i feel like
i use less dictionary reading bayonet
forward than i used when i read
blood meridian no i mean you know like
it's
words like salient yeah and things like
that that people aren't used to that you
gotta go
thank goodness you can just pull it up
on you yeah i've got a dictionary app on
my on my
on my phone i must say and it's very
useful
uh but hey if you want to come check
some of the stuff out you know we're
covering one angle today we're with uh
with joshua chamberlain we cover a bunch
more angles on these events
so if you want to come check that out
echelonfront.com we got
if you want to support us
while you support yourself
remember that old theme yes
support it's not old it's current it's
current huh i think today that's my
opinion you know but yes it is current
in my opinion so if you want to support
the podcast while you support support
yourself we have a mutually aligned
focus here yeah uh you can check out
jockofield.com get all kinds of good
stuff for your for your life what's your
latest and greatest
freaking mulk creation
you still you still throwing it in your
morning coffee little what are you
throwing there vanilla no i'm cutting
back on the milk in my morning coffee um
i'm just using it just straight anymore
just straight yeah
it's so tasty yeah i'm i've been i've
been mixing the banana and the peanut
butter doing this elvis thing
i can't stop
i can't i feel like that's what kind of
kill was one of the you know factors
that led to elvis death right
because this this dude was like
look he had a bunch of factors right yes
sir he hit a bunch of factors but one of
the factors was an excess of peanut
butter banana fried sandwich
cause that can't be good for you he was
unhealthy as hell that's the sad thing
is just
someone should have been like bro
hey
let's go let's go one every three days
on the fried sandwiches right
i tell you my latest thing is that the
the discipline go
in the pills oh yeah it's a winner every
morning that's just like with my coffee
oh really
okay and then if i'm speaking how many
did you take in the morning okay
on a regular day on a day that i'm
speaking
45 minutes before i speak i take two oh
yeah
and it is hating me when i come up and i
am on
fire yeah and so typically what i'll
suffer from and i don't know why this is
it's either getting older or or
traumatic brain injuries but i'll do a
lot or you're just dumb i'm just that's
my problem and it's like i'll do a lot
of word searching where i'm like oh you
know this or that i
nope
two of those things 45 minutes later for
the next hour and a half i am
cognitively on fire i'm pulling all the
words down i need
it's awesome you know when i have to
sometimes because i'll you know before
the podcast i'm i'm going i'm going uh
going with a can at least sometimes too
but like when you're speaking you can't
because you gotta pee yeah i know that's
the the drawback uh but
man
when i gotta read a lot
i'm gonna have to hit an afternoon go
can of gun
because you're starting to just starting
to not be you know in the in the mood
for reading dude on a freaking whatever
sunday
saturday
and you already worked out you rolled
the jiu jitsu you know you got that post
jiu jitsu fatigue yes you know what i'm
talking about
it's like
you leave jiu jitsu with a hype
kind of hyped you don't leave tired i
never leave i mean i'm tired physically
but mentally in the game
1.5 hours later
do i do not feel like freaking reading a
book at all that's what i was gonna say
they're like that po would you call post
jiu jitsu fatigue or whatever right yeah
it's i was gonna say it's kind of nice
to be honest when you don't got nothing
to do yeah yeah yeah if you got
something to do
you look at that as like an opportunity
to cruise
[Music]
that's true
it's true it's nice the opportunity to
cruise is good uh so anyways
jockofield.com you can check out some of
that stuff you want to get uh some gear
for yourself and you want to support
america
you want to support america yeah check
these out
i see jason gardner's wearing his uh
brand new how old are they
uh a couple months old no two weeks ago
oh two weeks ago yeah yeah they were
awesome the american bison boots with
the crisp black christie soul
loving it yeah and and i'd read you know
like rogan was talking about they took a
little bit of break in so i was nervous
about that i put some oil on them and
wore them for a day and a half no issues
yeah if you get that
leather so
so good out of the gate
we also make jeans
and sweatshirts and
hey i just so
when i got the boots
i got the built
pants pants yeah the work pants yeah
dude those things are like comfortable
like pajamas
i've never like i put on other work
pants it's like putting on cardboard
yeah and you put these things on you're
like oh wait a minute i'll see you know
about the durability that that remains
to be seen but they are so comfortable
and then
the way the pockets are lined out
really well thought out yeah freaking
legit and i love the fact that you that
you're wearing them up on the freaking
uh whatever you call your compound up
there
up north
every
day yeah those things are just like
you're wearing them for pajamas probably
in case you gotta go like kill a bear in
the middle of the night or something or
you have to clean up after your wife
killed the bear so check this out
there's there's some military guys up
there training right now and uh um
i'm flying down here last night
uh iris sends me a text and she the kids
had after school archery so she went to
go pick them up from school she's
driving home from school and this this
military unit that was up there the guys
had hit a deer
and they pulled over and they were kind
of standing there they didn't know what
to do and iris could see them and could
see the deer flopping
around in the middle of the road
pulls the car over grabs a 38 out of the
car and we care we we carry guns in the
car for this reason
because
deer get hit all the time on the road
and you want to put them on your misery
so i can only imagine what these guys
saw is she just
walked pulls over
these these are special operations yes
they are yeah crack crack two shots
what's going on peacock re-holster
[Laughter]
they're like oh uh
i'm like right on baby
that's freaking legit iris iris gardner
podcast 70 by the way go listen um go
listen to that hey what do you do with
the deer afterwards you just
call it off into the woods or what oh no
they have they have a thing you just
call fish and game oh and it's been hit
on the road and then um those guys
actually took it and and and butcher it
out uh
a lot of them get hit this time of year
because of the snow
and it winds up that they wind up being
great food for the um
the eagles and a lot of the raptors and
other wildlife because they're they're
looking for stuff to eat too so
nothing gets wasted
she got some amazing photographs of some
bald eagles recently that were
eating one of those roadkill deer
that is a legit story
iris
his kids are looking at it like it's no
big deal
mom's taking care of business oh yeah
so if you want to get those pants
go to or anything else all made in
america by the way which got a new
factory
um yeah so that's awesome we got a big
factory in north carolina now so our
capabilities are going to increase we're
going to continue to invest back into
the business back into the factories
back into the people it's just awesome
so if you want to support all that go to
originusa.com don't support
well straight up just don't support
companies that are
that are supporting the communist regime
don't do it
instead support american companies
origin usa.com and here's the deal
yeah that it costs more
but
when you when you buy something that's a
premium product
over the long haul it costs you less
because it lasts longer
and then you're reinvesting
that into your community which is our
country right
so yeah so do you just just don't be
like those corporations that that to to
make five dollars on a pair of pants
ship stuff overseas spend a little bit
extra money get a quality product it
will actually cost you less over time
and then you're supporting your
community yeah and it's so much better
for the world what do i mean by that
well when you're with all these
factories that are overseas they have no
they have no regulatory environment that
they're operating in they're just
dumping whatever they don't use into the
rivers and it's killing everything
america there's rules
there's rules not just for the
environment there's rules for the worker
there's all kinds of rules that we have
in place here so yeah is it going to be
a little bit more expensive yes it is is
it going to be a better product hell
yeah it is is it going to help america
those communities and the world yes it
actually is
so we appreciate that
jacquelinestore.com yep it's true did
you make up that name
yeah or did you just make up the t-shirt
it was a collaborative uh effort with
the name the naming on that one yeah for
sure but
good news is regardless of the name this
is where you can get
our
apparel if you want to represent on this
path no we're all on display equals
freedom good some new jiu-jitsu stuff on
there too yeah do we have a section now
official it's a fish
what's the latest of the jujitsu section
dean lister's foot shirt that he made up
by the way
oh yeah so that's an awesome shirt
does it say foot backwards no oh you
didn't go full layers huh well
that's not a layer in the enlisted foot
let's face it dean lister came up with
it so it's going to be pretty direct in
a lot of ways
you know if it would have said foot
backwards correct me if i'm wrong i
would have said tough
pretty tough
because he's tough yeah
peter greek you know pete the greek yeah
he's he's now saying um why would you
ignore five percent of the body
wrist lock the world
dude he's the last dude yeah sure he
makes a good point yeah yeah but yes
jack will store some good stuff on there
short locker is a subscription thing
don't forget about that
kind of cool yeah good reviews on those
especially the latest too i got one that
um you'll see it
but you came up with the design idea you
did 100
long time ago in what way you just came
up with it make a shirt like this and
you told me the idea i can't tell you
surprised you can't even tell me i made
it up right yeah i know that's why it's
going to surprise you more all right
we'll put it this way i'll give you a
hint there's a stoner gun involved oh
you made that shirt all i gotta say dude
i wanna can i see it i need to see it
what the shirt it's being printed right
now check i guess it looks good yes
jacquelinestore.com it's good awesome
hey uh subscribe the podcast check out
jockonderground.com look there's
let's face it yes it's getting wild
right now with this stuff with uh
suppression of voices things are getting
crazy
so
if you don't want to if you want to have
a backup plan to listen to us go to
jockowunderground.com it's eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month if you can't
afford that just email assistance at
jacquelineground.com there's censorship
happening i don't know when they're
gonna censor me maybe it's we shouldn't
be talking about war
or talking about america
in a positive way and we're going to get
censored for that
so when that happens we'll be on taco
underground.com
uh we got a youtube channel we got
psychological warfare flipside canvas i
written a bunch of books
ashland front we talked about that a
bunch um leadership consulting go to go
to echelonfront.com if you want to check
out the battlefield review with us we
have online training academy
it's called it's at extreme
ownership.com we're on there
i'm on there once two three times a week
jason's on there all the time leif the
whole crew we're all on there they're so
cool
answering questions going through these
details
of what we're talking about when we talk
about leadership leadership is a skill
it's a skill
it's not just something you know how to
do it's not no one just knows how to
lead it doesn't work you have to learn
it and so go to go to
extremeownership.com
we also have a couple charities we
support if you want to help service
members
active and retire
we've got mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a great charity organization
if you want to help out you want to
donate go to america's
mightywarriors.org and also check out
heroesandhorses.com
micah fink
got a great organization going that is
doing some incredible things for
veterans and he's an awesome guy so
that's cool if you need more of us we're
on social watch out for the algorithm
the algorithm is a is a thing it's an
active like enemy of this of of you
it's debatable
what part's debatable what the algorithm
yeah the algorithm is designed for
specifically it doesn't always get it
right
but it's designed to show you
what you
want to see more specifically it's
designed to show you what you want to
see so that you click on and watch more
it's trying it's so it is your enemy so
where i be so be careful
it could be viewed as what like the um
a deal with the devil kind of a thing
like can you get what you want you can
use it to your advantage though oh yeah
fully fully yeah you can't but you have
to use caution i mean yeah you can use
um
fire to your advantage but you have to
use caution and that's especially um
with you jason that's a very a very
pertinent item
so you can use fire you can use guns to
your advantage if you have to uh
eliminate or put a deer out of its
misery yeah you can also be a jackass
with guns so it's kind of like a um
double-edged sword dichotomy
so so we are on the social media watch
out for the algorithm is the warning
jason's at jason and gardner on
instagram with a period there's jason
period and period gardner on instagram
he's also jason n gardner no periods on
twitter
and for the twitter for the gram
and facebook echo's addictive charles i
am at jocko willink
and to
all the military personnel out there
around the world representing the flag
and all that it stands for
all that it's supposed to stand for and
protecting those ideals
around the world thank you and thanks
also to our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emt's
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all the first
responders
out there thank you for keeping us safe
here at home
and remember for everybody else that
there are some times when the odds are
stacked against you when things are
falling apart and when you're not sure
how much more you can take or what you
can do
there are times when things get truly
desperate
and sometimes in those scenarios the
best thing to do is like joshua
chamberlain and the 20th maine
is not to sit there and wait to die
but instead attack so fix bayonets
take action
and attack
and until next time this is jason and
echo and jocko
out